so in continuing with the collab reviews
I've been doing today we're gonna be
talking about 500 days of summer and I'm
bringing in my friend Blake Kennedy from
granite-- for life 27 it's a really good
friend of mine and we're gonna talk
about it for you
the boy Tom Henson grew up believing
that he'd never truly be happy until the
day he met the one girl summer Finn did
not share this belief you should know
upfront this is not a love story Wow
Chris this is what your channel smells
like all right let's get to it what are
we gonna talk about today 500 days of
Sumar did you mother is that you making
noises love you mommy
funny a man named Marc Webb got together
his friends Joseph gordon-levitt and
Zooey Deschanel and ironically one of
the writers for this movies last name is
Webber directors name is Webb Rodgers
lessons Webber anyways he got these
people together and he said let's make a
romantic comedy history people and they
all put their hands in the middle I went
yeah see this movie is really important
to me because it was the very first
movie that I ever actually traveled out
of my way to see it was the it was
before I started doing my reviews on
YouTube I was just going to the local
theater to see movies and it was the
first time I heard about it I was like
oh looks so good I decided to travel
like an hour away to the theater that
was showing it it was the first one
where I did that and boy did I pick a
good one
this is a rare movie that looks at a
relationship in a realistic way not
Hollywood eyes it tells it in a very
very true fashion it doesn't have any
lies about it and it also is a rare film
that tells the romance from the point of
view of the guy and that is very very
hard to find I think we should stop
seeing each other just like that just
like that start from the beginning and
tell us what happened I tried to talk to
her in the copy room she's totally not
having a B she was just in a hurry and
maybe she's an uppity better than
everyone super skank underneath the
summer is my 16th favorite movie of all
time yeah I'm that guy
500 days of summer does which I really
really appreciate is it is a romantic
comedy it's from the perspective of the
guy and I'm just gonna come out and say
it I don't think I can relate to any
movie as much as I can to this movie I
feel like I am this guy this movie
completely captures this guy's mindset
completely all these little tricks that
this film does that some people might
call pretentious or like - indie or
whatever you want to say all have
purpose they're all really clever
they're all really original there's a
lot of rich
in this movie but they all really
capture what those guys going through
this movie really perfectly captures I'm
saying that were capturing a lot but if
it was perfectly capture how
relationships and breakups affect our
lives I'm able to relate to this movie
so much because I've experienced things
like this and I've seen things like this
where it's happened to me and to other
people and it's just it's so real I've
always kind of liked Joseph
gordon-levitt you know I grew up with
him but this is one of the first movies
where I was like man this guy is gonna
be something also Marc Webb who's now
directing the amazing spider-man his
tone of this movie that his stylistic
view of the film he has some excellent
scenes in here particularly one called
expectations versus reality I will never
forget my first experience watching this
movie it meant so much to me when I was
seeing the theater
you ever even have a boyfriend what
happened my why didn't they work out
what always happens life
[Music]
I really do to this movie Joseph
gordon-levitt is one of my favorite
up-and-coming actors right now and I
think in this film he perfectly masters
the art of displaying a normal average
everyday guy but actually being an
interesting normal everyday average guy
Billy really really like this guy you're
really really interested in what's going
on with him film is hilarious but it's
also very insightful he already said
this movie refreshingly centers around
the guy in the situation not the girl
and it does that with actual sensitivity
not like a stereotypical guy but a guy
that actually has a heart you know
because I'm gonna come out and say it
girls screw over guys all the time in
real life how often do you see that in
movies every often it's usually the guy
screwing over the girl and I'm not like
I don't love this movie due to angst
that I have against women yeah tecna's
movies very very honest in regards to
its interpretation of these situations
it really changed my entire life
actually because like I said it was the
first like limited release film that I
that I sought out that I was like boy I
got to see that and I followed it I
figured out when it was coming to my
area and and it was such a good movie to
be able to start doing that on because
now I do it all the time and it really
helped me mature as a film goer and it
helped me to understand a lot more about
how Hollywood portrays and romance in
films because you know romantic comedies
that they're so cheesy and unrealistic
and pop songs and everything there's
actually a whole scene where Joseph
gordon-levitt's character talks about
that how romance is portrayed so
unrealistically in Hollywood and then
music and how everyone has these weird
expectations that aren't there
but get over I don't want to get over I
want to get it back
their days of summer is definitely one
of those movies that I wish there was
more of those movies that gives me hope
for the future of filmmaking I heard
that there is originality left in there
that someone can do something different
with a movie I definitely think there
needs to be movies as honest as this
film is be inspired by people's
situations that they've gone through I
can definitely tell that this movie was
inspired by the filmmakers we're all 500
days of summer is one of the most
charming funny clever honest films I
have ever seen it is one of my favorite
movies of all time like I said number 16
definitely recommend everyone who has
not had the chance to see it yet to see
it I don't quite the mouthful right what
my favorite ways of all time I give it a
10 outta 10 I don't know what else there
is to say you can watch me spin again
that's always fun
I'm already sick 500 days of summer is
my favorite romance film it's hard for
me to imagine another film being better
than it in the romance category it's
just it's so real it's so well acted
it's so cleverly written there are so
many great scenes in this film you
haven't seen it really suggest you check
it out I would get 500 aces somewhere in
a been like sitting Nancy for months now
we have some disagreements but I hardly
think I'm Sid Vicious
oh I'm Sid oh so I'm Nancy
so yeah take it away Creston or I don't
know I don't know maybe Christian in
this video maybe should like set his
pants on fire or something I don't know
thank you very much Blaine keep you guys
on check out his channel and be very
cool link is in the underbar and yeah
look forward to more classic reviews
coming from me and other youtubers I'm
working right now with any special
person on a Jurassic Park review so look
forward to that